I'm like admittedly a hoe I love your
content yeah I'm like give the people
what they want
I think Abraham Lincoln said that but
like what a me yeah exactly let them eat
cake
yeah okay welcome to an all-new would
you rather relationship Edition so my
relationship status is that I am
currently failing but clearly I'm going
o always working my relationship status
is great
and I am in a long-term relationship
with my boyfriend wait I didn't know
that you put all those traps on
Instagram oh that's what gay people do
that's gay culture okay I'm allowed your
boyfriend like pause okay would you
rather deal with your partner's bad
breath or have bad breath yourself have
bad breath
so I don't have to live through that
pain someone else looks to it I'm very
self-conscious I think I would rather
have that have bad breath I love my dad
but he had a dead tooth for a week or
two I couldn't deal with it
I think I would prefer to have the bad
breath I'm very sensitive miss so would
you rather I show you underwear with
your partner forever aren't you a
toothbrush with a partner forever brush
to brush and this isn't continuing on
from the bad breath ones yeah everyone's
thoughts good breath yeah yeah and I'm
sharing the toothbrush too mm-hm I would
rather share underwear but I guess like
yeah I mean we were I think we already
do like it's already like what's mine is
yours head situation that's one of the
best parts of being gay but yeah I love
sharing clothes toothbrush for me is
like but yeah I feel like that's a
little too much
would you rather date someone who's
really good in bed but boring or date
someone super smart who's terrible in
bed I really love boring
patience it's a lie I love but the thing
is if they're good in bed how could they
be boring so I would rather date someone
who's boring but good in bed because
ultimately I'm just dating that person
and I'm not gonna marry them yeah if
you're getting like good good like I
don't care if you like literally all you
talk about is like the like reciting the
dictionary like literally they could
tell me that their favorite color is
like bland but if you're making you talk
to God every time we're together I think
I need to shrink in my relationship with
the Lord
yeah I think we all I'm not surprised
that we all agreed on that one I like to
be like a postcard would you rather have
free tacos every day for the rest of
your loveless life or find true love but
never be able to eat tacos again I don't
know what you talk again so he does
literally I could cut my burrito up in
threes and that's a damn taco
would you rather date someone who here
BSF tapes and your mom loves or date
someone who your mom hates where your
BFF loves my mom loves see I am of the
school of mind that your mom needs to
love them but at the same time I think
I'm gonna pick the BFF loves and mom
hates I'm really gonna dig myself into a
hole in this yeah I also choose that
reason why would she says because you're
best friends
ultimately I think you know you better
than your mom and if your best friend
hates the dude it's just a sign that
you're gonna break up eventually and
then when you do break up you're best
friends like I told you so but it's okay
you'd rather hear from her than your mom
yes sure would you rather lose all the
photos you've ever taken with your
partner or lose all the gifts your
partner has ever given you I would give
up the gifts in a heartbeat
first of all because we've taken as gay
men we've taken a lot of amazing
shirtless pictures together but actually
real talk we've like been some amazing
places done some amazing things
like I would hate to lose I mean
obviously you still have the memory up
there but to me like like being able to
share those memories and like reminisce
on them down the road I think is so much
more important than any material item
like as well I would actually keep the
yes because I'm getting technical yeah I
am a photo person but I am more of a
video person
I will use my Instagram story and way
more than I do you know what I'm saying
because I love capturing moments would
you rather have your partner cheat on
you with their ex or have your partner
cheat on you with your ex for me I think
it's a no-brainer I'd rather have them
cheat with their ex because that feels
like more of a slip-up and less of like
a calculated move I don't know if that
makes sense well that makes a lot of
sense for me I guess I'm thinking if my
partner taking out with my accent is my
partner gay and they just didn't weren't
telling me yeah okay so how do you fluid
so okay sure so then I almost would
rather them hook up with my ex because
if they're burning themselves and great
oh I love how I didn't even like the
game where that question made everyone
else is happening her look at that game
but that's only also because I identify
as a straight woman here you're sleeping
flying I'm sorry I don't I don't care
what you're into I don't care what you
want you getting back with your ex the
same feeling
with when we got together then you're
getting back with their ex no and they
have feelings with the person and all
this stuff and they're like kissing
smooching weren't any poetry about that
no I'm number one
so if you gonna be with someone you're
gonna be with someone who just was
obsessed with me as you that question
customary rather than sleeping Maya okay
at least I know they're thinking about
they're both thinking about me while
they're sleeping with each other
haha it is yeah okay would you rather
have a partner who's hotter than you or
be hotter than your partner this is such
a dicey one I can't even logic whistle I
like personally think my husband is
insanely attractive so I'm gonna say
that he's hotter than me yeah I have a
very high self-worth but my boyfriend is
like total package like it's not even
just a looks then yeah it's like he's
the total so I'm like I love being able
to brag and be like yeah that's him like
I'm doing him so wrapped him up yeah
yeah yeah I'm like he's successful he's
smart he's hot he has a six-pack it's
handy he puts things together he's so
thoughtful
like if you're hot then it's like great
you hit the genetic lottery but this is
right I waited this yeah and that says
more I think then if you are like
attractive yourself totally yeah I
someone who is hotter than me but I want
them to think that I'm hotter than them
that's a great I feel like that's yeah
yeah yeah right where those people think
you're lucky to be in the yeah yeah like
human in a long-term relationship you're
married so obviously like damn that
I know that and you know every knows a
still you'll have moments where you're
like yeah what you were say yeah I know
I'm there with you I'm there with you
well besides Joy's getting a little
frantic yeah we touched a nerve with one
of the questions I think I stand across
the board we kind of felt the same way
about a lot of stuff it's I like that
you have like a noble approach and like
no games like straight up odelay
I like my food drive food you know yeah
or post favorite pose waited over eats
when I'm feeling thrashing
[Music]
you